bref brutal à la sncf dès ce soir 20h
sept syndicats appellent à 36 heures
d'arrêt de travail
la france demain au ralenti
27 heures de négociations dans la
fonction publique syndicats et ministres
se revoit demain
il retrouve la grille des salaires 1 à
bonal ce à moscou ce sera le plus grand
du monde les relations est-ouest placée
sous le signe du hamburger bonsoir et
tout d'abord l'exemple du ministre qui
fait des bêtises
michel charasse ministre chargé du
budget avait été contrôlé à 129 km heure
sur le périphérique est bien cet après
midi on lui a retiré son permis de
conduire pour huit jours devant les
journalistes ensuite monsieur charade
pas fera devant un tribunal et paiera
une amende
ainsi donc la france entière sera dès ce
soir un que les ministres sont punis
comme les autres même s'ils ont des
relations de que c'est bien de payer ses
amendes parce que ça va directement dans
les caisses du trésor donc du budget
dont monsieur charasse est responsable
olivier lerner récit d'une sanction
exemplaire pour son chauffeur personnel
qui sera vite saturé un bonheur pour les
chauffeurs de taxi michel charasse n'a
donc plus de permis de conduire on lui a
retiré sur le champ
26 août ni moralement par quelques amis
le ministre n'est pas allé jusqu'à faire
jouer toutes ses relations pour échapper
à la justice ne vient pas ce que fera le
lien voir comment les choses se passent
parce que votre queue
le fait que monsieur charest se fasse
devant la commission de retrait de
permis de conduire et bien c'est
pédagogique exemplaires et dissuasives
et la comparution n'a duré que trois
minutes
michel charasse a plaidé coupable il est
néanmoins ressorti libre hier chopper le
jour mais il ya toujours un moment où
mon chauffeur rentrer chez lui tant que
le soir si je dois sortir en ville je
vais dîner dehors je rentre chez moi
parce que j'habite pas seulement au
ministère
si j'ai une obligation quelconque je
prends le taxi avant d'en arriver là
michel charasse avait ordonnée lui-même
une enquête dans son ministère pour
démasquer un fou du volant jusque-là
anonyme
bon c'est le cabinet me dit l'anc est de
ne rien les chauffeurs disent que c'est
pas à eux etc
alors je lui dis bon bah faut que tu
faire communiquer la photo lp communiqué
la photo et je vois ma gueule dessus et
la nuit alors je me dis mais plus avec
elle une personne à côté de moi avec qui
j'avais dîné et que j'avais ramené chez
lui mais c'est dans l'adversité 01 29
les 27 octobre 01 29 et je vous jure que
j'ai pas vu le flash toison je l'aurais
vu sera réentendue peine minimum pour le
ministre trop pressé huit jours de
retrait pour d'autres ces deux mois le
ministre est tout de même reparti sur
les chapeaux de roue mais c'est son
chauffeur qui était au volant
la france paralysée de 36 heures de
grève à la sncf à partir de ce soir 20
heures et jusqu'à jeudi matin 8 heures
en gros un train sur quatre sur la
banlieue de paris comme sur les grandes
lignes parfois même un train sur cinq
seulement
de toute façon il faut que vous preniez
vos précautions et pour cela sachez que
les horaires des trains qui circulent
sont affichés dans les gares
alors pourquoi ce mouvement de grève
brutale décidé par six syndicats sur 7
jean-pierre motivé du jamais vu même les
tgv resteront à quai demain seulement un
sur quatre circulera exactement le même
quota que pour lui
banlieues ou ceux des grandes lignes et
pourtant le tgv c'est l'enfant gâté des
projets d'avenir la sncf aussi bien du
nouveau contrat de plan avec l'état que
du contrat d'entreprise sur 100
milliards d'investissements prévus d'ici
à 5 ans la moitié pour le seul tgv dont
la fréquentation triplera c'est le moyen
retenu pour assurer l'équilibré des
comptes de la sncf
avec bien sûr la fermeture des lignes
non rentables et une remise de dette par
l'état de 38 milliards pour les
syndicats c'est bien une politique du
tout tgv au détriment du service public
et avec suppressions d'emplois à la clé
c'est la présentation du contrat de plan
pour les cinq années à venir qui donne
une sncf plus libérale plus commercial
avec moins de services publics
donc pour les cheminots c'est une
réduction importante des effectifs moins
25000 et aussi dans le cadre de
l'orientation pour le voyageur le tout
tgv avec des risques de fermetures de
lignes ou de transfert sur route en 1965
les cheminots étaient 350 mille
aujourd'hui 200 milles dans cinq ans 180
me du coup de main il y aura peu
d'agents de maîtrise pour conduire l'été
j'étais à la place des grévistes même
leurs syndicats appellent à la grève
seuls les cadres de la cgc ne seront pas
dans ce mouvement
cela aussi ne s'était pas vu depuis 10
ans en 1990 la sncf va renouer avec les
bénéfices mais aussi avec l'unité
syndicale
en revanche bonne nouvelle pour les
parisiens qui empruntent la ligne a du
rer le conflit est terminé et les rames
ont recommencé à circuler dès ce soir
normal même chose pour les routiers ils
lèvent leurs barrages sur les routes
l'unostra l'organisation professionnelle
qui appelait au blocus a obtenu une
table ronde sur les revendications mais
il y encore eu aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de bouchons notamment dans les
bouches du rhône vous le voyez ici ou en
savoie aussi ou 600 camions étaient
encore bloqués tout à l'heure encore
battus pour les négociations dans la
fonction publique 27 heures de réunion
non-stop entre les syndicats et les
ministres tout le monde a jeté l'épongé
vers 18 heures et tout le monde se
retrouvera demain mercredi en effet les
négociations ne sont pas terminées elles
sont longues et difficiles car il s'agit
d'une refonte de la grille est une sorte
de révolution dans la fonction publique
maryse mano explication la durée
exceptionnelle de cette négociation près
de 30 heures non-stop va aboutir à un
résultat exceptionnel dû aussi la
fameuse grille des fonctionnaires nés en
1947 sous un gouvernement communiste
pourrait bien voler en éclats les cinq
syndicats modérés qui vont signer
l'accord s'engage à réfléchir avec le
gouvernement sur un projet de loi qui
supprimerait les quatre catégories de
fonctionnaires
de quoi faire bondir la cgt qui a
préféré quitter la table de négociations
dès hier soir
l'objectif introduire de la souplesse
dans l'évolution des métiers
l'état pourrait ainsi donner un coup de
pouce à certains métiers sans être
obligé de faire la même chose pour tous
ceux qui font partie de la même
catégorie
comme c'est le cas actuellement cette
véritable révolution est la suite
logique des coups de canifs successives
que la vieille grille a reçu cette nuit
déjà la suppression en ces temps de la
catégorie des la moins qualifiés était
acquise c'est environ 60 milliards de
francs sur 70 qui seront consacrées à la
réforme de la grille des fonctionnaires
mais au delà des améliorations d'indicés
de carrière on s'achemine vers une
rénovation totale de la fonction
publique
une fonction publique ou la promotion
individuelle aura désormais sa place à
côté de la promotion collective
le malaise des médecins maintenant les
internes et les chefs de clinique ont
décidé de voter la poursuite de la grève
des soins dans les hôpitaux
un conflit qui commence à durer alors
pour savoir si les difficultés des
jeunes médecins sont réels nous avons
décidé de 30 des exemples très concrets
aujourd'hui et demain dans nos journaux
de 20 heures
ce soir l'exemple de deux cardiologues
de paris de deux générations différentes
alain labouze dominique merlin au coeur
du problème
lui c'est un jeune médecin 35 ans
cardiologue pour une urgence dans le 19e
ils n'hésitent pas à traverser tout
paris il faut dire qu'il a le temps à
peine 1 de malades par jour
ici c'est le cabinet d'un cardiologue
réputé du quartier de l'étoile un
immeuble cossu une secrétaire
trente deux ans de métier et une
carrière hospitalière mener en parallèle
pour les deux générations de médecins
l'outil de travail de base est le même
c'est l'électro cardiogramme mais le
jeune cardiologue a décidé d'aller plus
loin et d'investir dans du matériel
encore plus sophistiquées environ 600
mille francs
peut-être pour faire la différence dans
une ville déjà saturé ans cardiologue
en attendant pour vivre après six mois
d'installation à paris il est obligé de
faire les gardes de nuit en clean
une situation qu'il espère transitoire
n'était pas avant tout cardiologue
installés en libéral de manière à ce que
vous respirez
je suis un médecin de ville
mais comme les revenus professionnels
libéraux sont insuffisants je prends des
gardes de réanimation cardiaque en
clinique de 17 heures jusqu'à 9 heures
le lendemain matin payer 750 francs j'en
prends moyenne 12 par mois mes revenus
professionnels libéraux sont de 16 mille
francs en moyenne puisque je vois entre
sept et dix patients par semaine
alors mes frais professionnels variés
entre 25 et 27 mille francs par mois les
places sont chères
et pourtant dans le milieu on reste
solidaire entre d'un côté les
cardiologues déjà en place et de l'autre
les nouveaux médecins formés à de
nouvelles techniques peut pas une
concurrence déloyale et où il essaye
d'aider essaye de s'en sortait peu mais
ils sont ils sont plus fort mais aussi à
ces nouvelles techniques
c'était évident mais ils n'ont peut-être
pas les mêmes problème non plus je pense
par exemple que certains cardiologues
qui sont installés en province on
banlieue qui n'ont pas toutes les
ressources peut-être hospitalière qui
nous avons à paris sont obligés d'avoir
leur appareillage
je pense qu'ils me d'amendés nombreux
dons qu'ils ont pour se défendre il faut
je crois que c'est dans la qualité la
défense finalement c'est pas c'est pas
dans dans le fait de
d'essayer de prendre les malades aux
autres c'est pas du tout ne s'est pas du
tout le but et une déontologie médicale
qui veut qu'on la respecte ne pas
toujours respecter non enfin il faut la
respecter
c'est indispensable ce que ne
comprennent pas aujourd'hui les jeunes
spécialistes c'est pourquoi ils n'ont
plus droit aux mêmes tarifs que leurs
aînés obligé pour des raisons de
limitation des dépenses de santé de se
suffire d'honoraires bloqué alors que
les plus vieux peuvent toujours faire
des dépassements d'honoraires la
médecine et l'argent ont toujours du mal
à faire bon ménage
la sphère anis naccache qui rebondit le
canard enchaîné qui est publié demain
affirme que l'elysée aurait pris
l'engagement de libérer anis naccache en
juillet 90 c'est pour cela qu'il aurait
arrêté sa grève de la faim il ya
quelques jours
naccache vous le rappelle avait été
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
à la suite de sa tentative d'assassinât
contre l'ancien premier ministre iranien
chapour bakhtiar deux personnes avaient
été tuées dans cet attentat
alors y at il eu des tractations entre
la présidence française et les
dirigeants iraniens ce soir en tout cas
il n'y a pas de réaction officielle à
l'elysée hervé brusini un processus de
libérations danis nakache est
effectivement engagé une confirmation
officieuse nous a bien été donné des
informations révélées par le canard
enchaîné selon l'hebdomadaire une date
serait même prévue le 14 juillet 90 pour
maître vergès l'un des avocats de
nakache
tout cela paraît très vraisemblable son
client dit il n'a pas stopper sa grève
de la faim sans garantie il pense que si
les autorités iraniennes se sont
manifestés seulement ce jour là après
140 jours de grève c'est qu'elle avait
des raisons sérieuses de penser que la
poursuite de sa grève n'avait plus
d'options parce que non seulement ils
avaient confiance en rendant les
autorités iraniennes mais ils
s'abaissent autorités iraniennes de
respecter sa position et le problème
posé par la grève de la faim de nakache
n'est pas un problème d' administration
pénitentiaire sans problème diplomatique
et 7 au plus haut niveau diplomatique
que l' affaire semble avoir été réglé
les récentes visites des officiels
iraniens ont permis semble-t-il de lever
l'hypothèque évoqué par françois
mitterrand pas de libération du détenu
anis naccache sous la pression d'une
grève de la faim en revanche avait-il
dit le moment venu on verra ce moment et
peut-être désormais
elle est bien arrivé à l'étranger
maintenant l'économie américaine
va-t-elle redémarrer le président bush
le croire mais les marchés financiers ne
sont pas du même avis hier le président
américain a présenté devant le congrès
son budget pour 91 réactions sceptiques
à washington jacquat bouchard il pèse
aussi lourd qu'un bottin téléphonique
équivaut à 6 fois le budget de la france
c'est le projet de george bush pour
l'année budgétaire 1991 pas de nouveaux
impôts a promis le ministre des finances
qui affiche un objectif ambitieux un
déficit réduit de 50% grâce un bond des
recettes
la maison blanche prévoit en effet des
rentrées supplémentaires en pariant sur
une croissance forte de l'économie
américaine george bush fait la part
belle aux investissements qui modèleront
la société de demain l'espace
l'environnement l'éducation des domaines
qui conditionne les nouvelles frontières
humaines dit il
il octroie également des ressources
supplémentaires à la lutte contre la
drogue
al'inverse pour les militaires c'est le
temps des vaches maigres avec l'abandon
de quelques programmes et des fermetures
de base notamment en grande bretagne en
italie en grèce et en turquie
c'est la rançon du dégel en europe de
l'est ou en droit c'est un budget de
guerre froide estime pourtant un
sénateur démocrate qui exige davantage
d'économies pour la défense l'opposition
démocrate et glissez couteau elle est
très critique envers le projet de george
bush irréaliste dit elle surtout en ce
qui concerne l'économie qui ne va pas
très bien
au congrès les démocrates ne feront
aucun cadeau
alors que des élections municipales et
parlementaires sont prévues au mois de
novembre aux états unis
faire la très mal au kosovo cette petite
province yougoslave où les albanais de
souche sont en majorité hier il y encore
eu deux morts
et aujourd'hui des milliers de personnes
manifestaient michel mompontet malgré un
nom d'état d'urgence malgré des
centaines d'arrestations
système policier permanent les
indépendantistes albanais du kosovo
n'ont rien perdu de leur détermination
et il le prouve chaque matin face à la
police et à l'armée dépêchée sur place
par belgrade
ces derniers jours la situation ici
s'est empirée elle a pris des
proportions dramatiques
les manifestants étaient armés et
n'hésitant plus à tirer sur les forces
de l'ordre
certains d'entre eux ont déjà entamé une
véritable guérilla urbaine
leur but être indépendant rompre les
liens avec la serbie qui actuellement
contrôler leur vie politique et
économique de venir au moins la 7ème
république indépendante de la
yougoslavie
mais belgrade répondent y est lâché le
kosovo c'est accepter ni plus ni moins
que l'éclatement du pays tout entier
alors serbes et albanais sont condamnés
au seul dialogue des fusils hier encore
deux manifestants ont payé de leur vie
cette impasse qui est la république
fédérale de yougoslavie en bulgarie un
congrès extraordinaire du parti
communiste comme dans les autres pays le
post le pc bulgare part aussi en
lambeaux monsieur mladénov le nouveau
numéro 1 bulgare a très violemment
condamné son prédécesseur mais en
bulgarie les conservateurs les
communistes garde un poids important
dans le parti communiste qui est
maintenant donc très divisée en pologne
le parti communiste lui ce qui s'appelle
le pouf vous savez le parti communiste
s'est transformée il ya quelques jours
c'est maintenant un parti social
démocrate mais ces changements ne sont
pas toujours facile à gérer notamment
pour toute la presse communiste qui
dépendaient du groupe dominique derda
françois granier reportage chez des
confrères embarras varsovie ce matin
est-ce que vous avez tribuna n'entendent
plus boon est non il n'y en a plus
comment ça se fait effectivement j'avais
un mal fou à le vendre ce journal
il m'en restait d'étincelles tous les
jours quand gallas ans depuis le congrès
depuis les changements intervenus au
parti les gens se l'arrachent pourquoi
ce qu'elle change et j'en ai vendu 100
en une heure la tribune du congrès a
remplacé la tribune du peuple
c'est beau mâle ou d'autres organes de
toujours du parti communiste polonais en
un week end
le quotidien a changé de nom comme le
nouveau parti il se dit aujourd'hui
social démocrate
à la rédaction du journal ambiance
plutôt morne journalistes militants ils
doivent désormais changé d'opinion
facile de s'adapter aux changements
quoi qu'on en dise quand on est
tellement des communistes comment on
devient ton journaliste social démocrate
c'est d'être un journaliste honnête et
de rester fidèle à ses idées je répète
il faut être professionnel
certes mais inquiet inquiet de ne pas
plaire à la nouvelle direction d'avoir
l'empreinte d'un communisme passé de
mode
est ce que vous craignez vous d'être
licencié demain par le nouveau parti
social-démocrate par exemple au sol
personnellement j'aimerais beaucoup
continuer à travailler mais des
journalistes peu sur le chômage
c'est un jour à l'autre tête au parti
avant tout était simple le parti et lui
seul distribuer les cartes la ligne
semble être assez pour l'éternité
c'était si bien avant
conséquence inattendue des événements de
l'est la fuite des juifs soviétiques en
israël bien sûr c'est un véritable c'est
une véritable hémorragie et cet afflux
de nouveaux immigrants inquiète beaucoup
de monde en israël les juifs bien sûr
mais aussi les palestiniens charles
enderlin pour itzhak shamir ses notes de
musique sont d'autant plus douce à
entendre qu'elles sont joués par des
musiciens
récemment arrivée du rss le premier
ministre israélien était venu à rishon
le zion près de tel-aviv répondre aux
questions des immigrants est d'abord
celle de savoir si israël construire a
suffisamment de logements
monsieur chat me répond que
l'immigration est devenue la principale
priorité nationale et l'arrivée de cette
vague d'immigration changera le
caractère économique et social
au rythme actuel de l'immigration en
cinq ans la population juive d'israël
devrait augmenter de 25% et atteindre
les 5 millions d'habitants
il faudra construire des quartiers
entiers créer de nouvelles industries
surtout dans le centre du pays car la
plupart des nouveaux immigrants ne
veulent pas s'installer en cisjordanie
ou à gaza
tout cela va coûter très cher au budget
israélien déjà déficitaire retrouver
dans le budget de l'état à les fonds
nécessaires et je crois qu'en premier
lieu
ce seront les dépenses militaires qui
devront être coupée pour permettre
l'intégration de cet immense immense
vague d'immigrants l'arrivée de dizaines
de milliers de techniciens et
d'ingénieurs déjà formés devrait
compenser une réduction des dépenses
militaires
ils n'ont plus qu'à apprendre l'hébreu
dans des classes spéciales comme celle
ci mais l'immigration du rss suscite un
profond mécontentement dans les
quartiers défavorisés où en est persuadé
qu'elle se fera sur le compte des
budgets sociaux que le gouvernement va
donner des appartements russe alors
qu'ici les jeunes couples n'ont pas les
moyens de se loger se va être
l'explosion sociale
les palestiniens ne sont pas moins
inquiets ils perdent eux l'argument
démographique et craignent la création
de nouvelles implantations mais nous
nous avons une crainte immense de des
juifs du rss s'installe à jérusalem est
où dans les territoires occupés mais
nous demandons au gouvernement américain
d'intervenir auprès d'israël pour
empêcher cela
quant aux ouvriers palestiniens qui près
de tel-aviv construisent des logements
pour les nouveaux venus
ils disent qu'il ya la paix tout le
monde pourra venir à paris maintenant la
suite du procès des terroristes du cfppa
fouad ali salah l'organisateur a baissé
le ton des injures
mais cette fois il s'en est pris à tout
le monde y compris aux victimes au
palais de justice
dominique verdeilhan à la 10e chambre
correctionnelle de paris
insultes imprécations prière sur la
toile de fond de cette deuxième journée
d'audience
saleh n'a pas été expulsé il est
pourtant intervenu violemment à
plusieurs reprises salé qui tutoie le
président et qui traite le substitut le
fils de porc et de petits pharaons
saleh qui s'adresse aux victimes
présentes dans la salle en les pointant
du doigt ces femmes qui nous regardent
avec des yeux pleins de haine
il faut leur expliquer nous n'avons pas
de haine contre elle nous on n'est pas
content de poser des bombes
mais il faut qu'elles sachent que
pendant ce temps là nos enfants crèvent
de faim cessé de toiser les victimes
vous l'aurez fait suffisamment de mal
clame un des avocats de la partie civile
mes salles et continue ses vociférations
l'islam apportera le feu c'est par la
voie de l'islam et par notre ep que dieu
or à sa victoire d'un bon une des
victimes se lève et lance à l'adresse de
saleh
dieu ne tue pas entre insultes et
imprécations le président malherbe a
tenté de définir les responsabilités de
quelques-uns des inculpés avez vous
quelque chose à déclarer à sanaa roi
hassan à roy ne répond pas dans le box
il a disparu entre deux gendarmes
il fait sa prière remarque désabusée le
président du tribunal
cinq mesures décidées par le ministère
de la justice pour prévenir de nouvelles
évasions il s'agit du problème des
prisons qui vivent depuis deux mois une
véritable hémorragie de détenus cinq
mesures donc avec une amélioration des
contrôles d'individus
notamment des mesures pour l'instant
plus technique que concrète and gas
burgel lannemezan début décembre 9
évadés une semaine plus tard quatre
détenus de la prison de mende se font la
belle par la grande porte
le 18 janvier à périgueux ils sont trois
à s'évader selon le plan classique
course sur les toits plus cordes et de
draps enfin le week-end dernier c'est de
la prison de loos les lille que quatre
détenus s'échappe au total 25 évadés des
prisons françaises
en moins de deux mois une véritable
hémorragie que l'administration
pénitentiaire va tenter de juguler une
vigilance accrue qui passe par cinq
mesures amélioration des contrôles
individuels
les fouilles de cellules et de détenus
devront être plus systématique plus
ciblées il s'agit de faire la part des
choses entre le voleur de poules et le
gros truands amertume des syndicats
lorsqu'ils concernent la revendication
première des personnels c'est-à-dire le
renforcement des effectifs
or là dans les cinq mesures qui
apparaissent il n'est pas question dé
renforcement des effectifs protection
des établissements et intervention des
forces de l'ordre
il faut entretenir et renforcer les
liaisons phonique avec les commissariats
troisième mesure mieux équiper les
prisons la seule mesure qui apparaît à
mes yeux quelque peu positive c'est la
mesure c'est le plan d'équipement
accélérer l'acquisition du matériel de
sécurité et avec les crédits alors est
il reste à savoir que de quel ordre vont
être secret vie et quel est le matériel
devra convaincre
en outre les chefs d'établissement
doivent travailler plus étroitement avec
les préfectures enfin un délégué à la
sécurité des établissements viendra
renforcer l'autorité de chaque directeur
régional peu d'espoir pour les 19
membres d'équipage d'un cargo grec le
flag théophane au avait disparu dans la
tempête lundi soir en manche 2 cores et
une épave ont été retrouvés au large
portsmouth mais pour l'instant ces
décors et cette épave n'ont pas été
identifiés d'autres informations tout de
suite
louis carzou
pour la deuxième année consécutive edf
dans le rouge en 89 4 milliards de
déficit
la direction de l'entreprise nationale a
feeling la douceur de l'hiver des
hausses tarifaires insuffisante et la
sécheresse cette dernière avait rendu
nécessaire la remise en route des
centrales au fioul et au charbon
augmentation de 2,5 pour cent à partir
de jeudi 0 heure de la taxe intérieure
sur les produits pétroliers
conséquence directe le litre de super et
d'ordinaire devrait augmenter de 9
centimes
le super sans plomb de 806 et le gazole
de 5 centimes des taxes représentent
désormais plus de 76% dans le prix d'un
litre de super bass et a décidé
d'accorder une aide d'urgence aux
victimes de la tempête de la semaine
dernière d'un montant total de 2,6
millions d'écus soit plus de 18 millions
de francs
cette aide sera réparti entre la france
la grande bretagne la belgique la rfa et
le danemark
un nouvel avis de forte tempête a par
ailleurs été lancé pour cette nuit
tu as deux noveski reçu à strasbourg
devant l'assemblée des 23 pays membres
la pologne demande officiellement son
entrée au conseil de l'europe
le premier ministre polonais a précisé
que son pays s'efforçait de remplir les
conditions d'admission
depuis quelques mois la pologne
bénéficie du statut d'invité spécial
auprès du conseil
faute des changes le marché est resté
très calme aujourd'hui la bourse de
paris n'a pas pu prolonger la reprise de
la veille
la séance s'est achevée sur une baisse
de 0 67%
la devise américaine en revanche a
repris quelques couleurs à 570 j'ajoute
cette dernière information une
bibliothèque internationale d'art à
paris c'est jacques lang qui l'a annoncé
la france en effet va se doter d'une
bibliothèque internationale d'art qui
sera installé dans les locaux
prestigieux de la bibliothèque nationale
rue de richelieu vous savez que la bn va
bientôt partir à tolbiac avec les
nouveaux bâtiments et biens
dorénavant donc je me suis mis 32
caméras et à la place donc dans les
lieux précis dans les locaux prestigieux
de la bibliothèque nationale vont scène
va s'installer cette bibliothèque
internationale d'art avec des fonds
notamment les fonds de dans l'est qui
étaient installés dans les locaux très
vétustes de la bibliothèque d'art et
d'archéologie celle de la rue michelet
avec aussi les fonds littéraire
exceptionnelle conservé à la
bibliothèque sainte-geneviève et
d'autres font donc une grande
bibliothèque d'art à paris à la place de
la bn les relations est-ouest tendance
fast-food un restaurant mcdonald's ouvre
à moscou et comme les américains croient
à l'entente cordiale ce sera le plus
grand mc donald's du monde 1250 repas à
l'heure pour cela c'est toute une
organisation et tout un système
d'approvisionnement
corinne pertuis georges en scène big mac
au pays des soviets
depuis quelques mois déjà la première
des boissons américaines donner la
température qu'il fait à moscou
maintenant place pouchkine entre
l'avenue marx et l'avenue kalinin le roi
du hamburger s'est installé dans un
restaurant de plus de 2000 mètres carrés
il ne sera ouvert que demain mais déjà
les moscovites peut-être par habitude
font là que je vais y aller parce que
j'ai faim et qu'il n'y a pas assez
d'endroits pour manger à moscou mais
j'ai une question est ce que ce sont nos
produits ou les leur pain farine lait
viande pommes de terre mêmes salades
tout vient des fermes d'union soviétique
surveillés et contrôlés par mcdonald's
les employés ont subi un entraînement
spécial dirigé par les meilleurs
professeurs de l'université du hamburger
de toronto une université qui existe
vraiment c'est impeccable et filles et
l'attitude de la direction envers nous
et très sympa on se sent bien
si les produits les employés sont
soviétique les méthodes elles sont bien
américaine principe numéro un la
propreté la presse internationale
conviée à la visite de l'usiné devait
elle aussi montrer patte blanche
ma philosophie c'est le business
nous sommes là pour longtemps nous
espérons que d'autres entreprises
étrangères vont s'installer ici pour
soutenir la pérestroïka nous croyons
dans le futur de ce pays
en tout 50 millions de dollars qui
seront investis
vingt autres restaurants devraient
s'ouvrir à moscou le soviétique lui
devra dès demain ils dépensaient si
roubles environ pour manger ce qui est
assez cher le salaire étant ici de 200
roubles en moyenne par mois
enfin il aura le plaisir unique de
manger comme tous les autres peuples de
la terre
et pour terminer on célèbre le cirque
puisque ces jours ci au cirque d'hiver
se tenait le 13e festival mondial du
cirque de demain
un constat le site des années 90
privilégie surtout la gymnastique
l'exploit physique
gérard dalmaz sentent brisset en pis
les stars du cirque de demain les voici
avec ce lever de rideau sur 47 numéro
totalement inédit de 23 nations déjà
médaillée dans ce festival
le cirque du soleil montréal avec cette
femme araignée et ses trois compagnes
les deux demoiselles contorsionniste 11
à présent
et
peut-être le métier le plus dur et le
plus sensible si tous mpt la relève avec
cette jeune femme peint paulina
argentine ce festival 90 c'est la
multiplication des femmes déjà une
promesse fait de la danse et de la danse
fait ce qu'elle continue tout en faisant
les écoles de cirque continue à faire la
danse et continue à faire des exercices
de souplesse quel que soit le numéro
fait le fond cette fois par le trapèze
ça continue à faire de la danse est un
signe assad et souhaite donc
après ces métiers destinés aux femmes
pour l'épanouissement le phare le grand
gymnastes soviétique viktor fo mines
veille sur l'entraînement de marina
golovin sky qui a 19 ans et déjà
surnommé la divine
regardez on en retient son souffle
beaucoup de nouveau dans ce carrefour
mondial exemple les marocains excellent
dans l' équilibre main à main on est
tous très heureux de faire cette
compétition ici à paris a pour montrer
notre numéro 1 européen et tout ça est
pour quand au festival de demain
réservoir de talents alors les
directeurs des spectacles du monde
entier barnum lido las vegas viennent y
puiser des numéros nouveau d'autant que
le cirque est en pleine évolution
toute une série de renseignements
pratiques et de rendez vous d'abord des
résultats ceux du tiercé quinté plus qui
se courait aujourd'hui l'ordre d'arrivée
c'est le 19 le cincle 13 dans l'ordre
840 francs dans un ordre différent 168
feront un petit tir c'est 15 5 13 c'est
bien dit ça pour le quinté + c'est qu'un
5 13 16 et 11
là je vous laisse lire les rapports sur
l'écran parce qu'il y en a trop
la météo s'est tout de suite avec
laurent cabrol il va vous donner des
nouvelles de la tempête qui souffle déjà
et qui va souffler sur toutes les côtes
atlantiques et qui a déjà fait des
dégâts dans le sud ouest
à 22h10 22h15 n'oubliez pas carnet de
route l'émission de christine ockrent
alain gibert se consacrer ce soir à
l'immigration clandestine du sénégal aux
ateliers clandestins de la région
parisienne en passant par les frontières
passoires dernière édition ce sera
philippe lefait vers 23h 23h10 du coup
il y aura encore auto rendez vous télé
maintient bien sûr l'énergie et morin
partir de 6h30 demain aux 4 vérités
henri krasucki sera l'invité de françois
ponchaud les voilà bonne soirée sur
antenne 2 à demain 20 heures